I'm on the date right now we're on the
roof stop doing that so today I'm going
on a blind date with a vampire I'm
Anthony montemagno I'm part of a I guess
you'd say clan or a coven called the
saber-tooth clan and father Sebastian is
he's a bank sniff he made these for me
my only experience with vampires is
watching Twilight I only watched the
first two movies because the second one
was [ __ ] let's be real and then you get
a name that relates to something that
you do in life mine was odious and arias
is like a gatherer of people also says
the only history in swine so I was like
that sounds like me oh my goodness I
don't know anything about vampires I
mean I know that they drink pretty girls
blood so I mean hey choosing to be a
vampire I guess who says is like a value
system I'm not really trying to be
immortal for a guy so if that's what
he's expecting on the first date it's
not gonna have it I mean most of the
people I've dated or non vampires I
guess I'm a very opposites attract kind
of guy I'm not Bella I'm sorry
[Music]
I'm Anthony I'm salami sOooo cool that's
interesting name okay love it love the
hair Anthony I like your hair too yeah
I'm excited to do this I don't know what
we're gonna be doing but I'm sure it'll
be fun
actually we're gonna be going to Museum
of Death and then we'll have a Italian
place down the street called fabuloso
Kachina and have some dinner there and
then finish off here at the building on
the top of the roof was some wine
vampires romantic okay let's do it
so we started the date by going to the
Museum of death I was really excited
because I kind of have a small
fascination with death was excited to go
in but it was a lot just when the museum
of death can't shoot on camera Museum of
death was interesting there were
pictures of serial killers and the
victims aides slain there were real
pictures of bodies inside of there the
informative things that were cool is
like the mortician side of the autopsies
ever performed and how they did it so it
was a lot especially for a date I'd say
it's worth checking out but it's
definitely a lot to read and see or head
and do the restaurant now alright so I
have questions
yeah what kind of music do you a couple
of bands ones called neon coven Co Ven
you know like love electronic dance rock
the other ones called music is kind of
like a opera round it's actually kind of
vampire rock in a way I don't think I've
heard opera like Transylvania and like
you look back in old times like movies
et al to organ playing well there's
vampires and like oh it's very gothic do
you have any pets I have three gargoyles
in my room the other made of stone ones
Vladimir what is
then and then I have a bat like a
taxidermied bat there's my other pet
what about this man I have a dog no
guard girls do you talk to them do you
feed them
no I just keep airbrushing them I paint
their nails oh that's sweet
let's walk into fabulous vampires
favorite restaurant a lot of garlic so I
got to be careful
unfortunately I love it so they gave me
this pill that I could take it's like
lactate for garlic it's dinnertime so he
has to take out his fangs you can take
these out because I don't want to
swallow on accident speech so what are
you gonna eat as long as you're not
trying to drink my blood I'm happy
so do you sleep in the day I actually do
sleep in one for myself and I have like
my room is very blacked out I'm this
close to actually sleeping and I
actually do have a basement we got a
wonderful dinner steak of course it's
rare because he loves blood and you have
here is the special of the night it's a
handmade gnocchi pesto with the shrimp
pesto is made from basil parmesan olive
oil
my mother's garlic kind of - obviously I
left that out because I'm a bad eye no
no darling
okay there's other ways so we just
finished dinner it was really good
amazing customer he got a lot of garlic
today I was worried about him
fortunately the wine counteracts the
effects of garlic what has been your
fascination with papers honestly I just
don't believe that big zits or the
derry-o I used to hope the baby I think
I've never seen ones and yet here you
are right do you usually tell everybody
that your vampire
what vampire really means to me is that
the music I write is gothic and it was
inspired by vampire films my love of Tim
Burton film he kind of gave me a really
good window into like the worlds of
vampires you know they're people just
like you and me just with fake fangs the
rooftop was really nice we had a view of
Los Angeles and really nice chairs
and so it kind of just was a great way
to end the date was a good date I've
heard that before you were great okay
you're super fun he was super fun great
energy and that's what's important date
tonight it was super fun
had a great time salon was a great
person made a lot in common
she's very intrigued by the whole
vampire culture hanging out with Anthony
was kind of an eye opener it kind of
exposed me to the fact that this is
really just a community of people that
have a lot of similar interests I think
this has really enhanced my interest in
vampire culture first blind date I went
on with the vampire and it was great
he's a really cool person
maybe I'll even get my own pair of
famous you will second date
getting fangs
[Music]